zation has as one of its main missions
to stimulate the discussion of ideas to
solve some of the conflicts that could
threaten global stability it is not an
exaggeration to say that precisely the
Kashmir conflict is one of those that
truly threaten global global stability
and security in itself the Kashmir
conflict which caused has caused nearly
sixty thousand deaths in the past 13
years it's a matter of great concern but
the danger posed by the conflict has in
recent years acquire a much bigger
dimension it is good to remember that in
year two thousand then President Clinton
said that Kashmir is the most dangerous
place in the world today so this has
become evident particularly in recent
months one of President Clinton's aides
Bruce Riedel has revealed and I don't
know where that's right but is still
very impressive to know about it that
revealed that during the height of one
of the several armed conflicts between
India and Pakistan in the summer of
nineteen ninety nine Pakistan was
repairing nuclear weapons for possible
use a direct intervention by President
Clinton averted a threat at a time but
even today over a million troops on both
sides of India Pakistan understanding
eyeball to eyeball in their dispute over
Kashmir to throw up with some light on
this complex struggle and indicate
and this is very word possibilities for
a solution we have this afternoon by the
tool and I not exaggerating when I say
two of the most distinguished experts on
this matter in the world MJ aqua admin
is the editor-in-chief of the Indian
newspaper the Asian age and author of
many books on the Indian subcontinent
his most recent book a shade of the
sward jihad and the conflict between
Islam and Christianity in addition to
the expertise gained through reporting
on the Kashmir problem for over two
decades mr. Akbar brings a unique
insider knowledge of the latest state of
the conflict two months ago he was made
a member of India's Kashmir committee a
private organization with government
backing created to initiate dialogue
with the Kashmir separatist groups and I
also pleased to tell you that today he
will release the results of an opinion
poll in Kashmir that his paper
Commission to nielsen as the Pakistan
Afghanistan and Central Asia
correspondent of the far eastern
economic review and of The Daily
Telegraph mr. Ahmed Rashid has followed
the Kashmir dispute for two decades to
he also writes for The Wall Street
Journal his book Taliban militant Islam
oil and fundamentalism in Central Asia
has been on the New York Times
bestseller list for 10 weeks and it has
been translated already into 20
languages Amma's Rashid is also the
author of jihad the rise of militant
Islam in Central Asia so please now we
will pay attention for us to mr. up
then of course to you welcome this is
being recorded thank you very much I
don't know what level of expertise we
have but our profession has made us
experts on the subject if nothing else
just to correct you a little on the
kashmir committee which has been
actually of maybe at a later stage we
will discuss it but it is not
government-backed the last time we had
interaction with the government we had
both the Prime Minister and Home
Minister distancing themselves from us
with kind of great trepidation and
wondering whether we were fools trading
where angels fear to tread some of us
are foods but me to believe that
foolishness is necessary when it comes
to trying to find a solution peacefully
or anyone who likes pieces of fool these
days
the to come back to I think the way we
structured it between a mother and
myself is that I will try and give you
some overall historical background to
the problem which I believe is actually
very necessary and then members will
take up i think the perspective from his
side of the border and then perhaps i'll
take up the perspective from my side and
the border and i do hope that the line
of control is in his hands you do know
enough to realize that the key word in
this whole problem is a word called
partition I partition because it has
become so closely associated with India
Pakistan Korea even Vietnam until
Vietnam sorted this out seems to be a
very Asian or African reality in fact
partition was the favored exercise or
the favored behavior pattern of the
great European European powers in the
19th century this is what they were
doing to European powers to European
nations just about all the time and it
was the fate of almost anyone who was
defeated in a European war to get
partitioned with Poland being the most
laid off partition country and almost
any army which passed by took a piece of
Portland and left it back on the retreat
so partition wasn't a terribly new
concept except when Europe began
applying it to a fresh air in the 20th
century and it is very interesting that
whereas the conquered lands of Europe
where partitioned and divided because
nobody was a clear Victor divided
between the victorious pass when it came
to colonization of Africa Africa in Asia
the the conquering paths actually United
large land masses India was divided into
maybe
700 India had a civilizational unity
India had a cultural unity and and I am
very happy to see the map because there
will be a couple of romantics who will
probably look at India from Herath right
up to assault as it has a as as as a
single entity that might have been no
could have been and so on certainly this
is the future common market if we are
all lucky I don't know about being unity
of unity or not but this is the future
common market if we are lucky so far the
evidences we are not going to be better
and when the British came to India and
they were the first ruling power to
actually come from the east almost every
other ruling power that had come to
Delhi that had reached delhi had come
back Afghanistan had come to I Punjab
the British were the first to come by
these because they were also the first
to come by ships through naval park and
they crept up from Calcutta onwards in
stages the philosophy of British power
was very very interesting of British
imperialism all that the East India
Company did was actually rig all the
ships and provide the initial funding
after that Empire had to expand on the
basis of its own profitability they
never financed the and that they did
they actually conquered India with the
wealth of India you can see it happening
virtually in stages first place near
Madras chennai now which is a very
uncertain history then the move of life
to calcutta which has a curiosity
created the newest of the indian cities
and created by the british from Calcutta
the finance of Calcutta won them are
very small and minor engagement in 1857
in plassey the village called policy
that policy gave the Musha debod when
tribe entered murshidabad which by the
way bangor was never the richest part
vindhya min ball was swampy had poor
economics it had alleged brains but
those brains never ever got converted
into an economy and from the but when
Clive entered murshidabad he wrote back
saying that Marcia daba the capital of
Bengal at that time was many times
richer than London which brings us back
to a very important point that nobody
ever wants to conquer a poor country
except America and Afghanistan without
soda principal sir the wealth of
murshidabad took them to buxar near
Patna which is a famous battle major
Monroe buxar took them to Allahabad
where they built of the first internment
Allahabad took them to the wealth of
Bihar then took them into avada of earth
took them to ramp or rampu took them
eventually it's 1800 and 3 into the
conquest of them but the British in
gradual stages unified all the regions
that they conquered because colonialism
is economic exploitation and economic
exploitation is better done through one
entity and I I do apologize that's the
trouble with this yes to apologize I
must come to meet this is well regarded
they are the historian events all right
we come to 47 which is the end of the
british empire in 47 as you know the the
movement that made pakistan was
successful jenna was successful and two
options were offered to there were two
grounds on which the definition of india
and pakistan was going to form there was
really never much trouble about you know
what the landlocked areas where the
muslim or hindu would go but the border
areas there was some trouble about which
was who would go in with side and the
the according to the mountbatten theory
the options were demographic majority
and contiguous both principals had to be
established around these principles
actually vote and a plebiscite was held
in certain parts of the Bangor wat is
now the Bangladesh product and certainly
in junagadh which is on the South but in
on when Doug partition and when
independence came to India and Pakistan
three regions were not given did not
find freedom one was Kashmir one was
hyderabad in the center of 20 and the
third was a small principality called
junagadh Kashmir to come down to Kashmir
the Maharaja of Kashmir had what is
known as a standstill agreement a
standstill agreement was signed by both
Delhi and Karachi at that time by which
the status of cash meat was left left as
it was now the interesting fact is that
this status of Kashmir could not have
remained in limbo Mountbatten was still
around jinda was still around and
discussions would have taken place on
the future of Kashmir and the formula
would have had to be found peacefully
but before any peaceful formula could be
found on 23rd October 21st October 1947
what today would be called cross-border
terrorism took place a large number of
large number of Afridi slams number of
patents raised from the tribal areas
were sent across to take by force what
had not yet been decided who's a fate of
a region which had not been decided on
the table and this effort at seizing
Kashmir by phos made by the Pakistan
government without technology that it
was doing so calling it a local
insurrection or a uprising was
eventually matched by an Indian response
and Indian response that was sanctioned
by Lord Mountbatten one of the very
interesting aspect of the story is that
is that while the Indian Army moved
because it had the sanction of Lord
Mountbatten who remained governor
children and the commander-in-chief of
Indian forces when Gina wanted
the Pakistan Army to intervene on the
other side the Pakistan Army actually
refused to do so because the Pakistani
army was still taking instructions in
that early grave period from the British
High Command in London and indirectly
from Jenna the indirectly from Lord
Mountbatten so this was one of the
reasons that enabled the Indian rip
response to be as effective the line
that you see right there is actually the
line that was drawn on the first of
January 1948 this is the thin slice on
the left was remained with Georgia South
remained with Pakistan and the rest came
with the Indian process to get into the
complications of what happened later on
would certainly take more than eight
minutes that I hear and I don't really
want to get bogged down into too much
detail but this is the origin since then
there has been there have been two or
three aspects of the problem that have
never gone away one is the desire of a
certain number of kashmiris to stress
that without the plebiscite that was
promised by India during the times of
the negotiations they would be there
could be no permanent solution to the
problem the other was the gradual the
gradual position of the government of
india that after the 1956 constitution
ratified by the Jammu and Kashmir
assembly the problem of gratification
and its union with the government of
with the union of india was no longer a
debate and an issue the practical fact
is that what the situation that you see
today in Kashmir what has emerged in the
last ten years has not really had a kind
of echo in the past because there has
been no major Kashmiri insurrection
movement since 48 53 53 was the worst
point when sheikh abdulla who was the
leader of the Kashmiris who actually
joined india and joined india because he
wanted to remain with the secular
dispensation rather than with the
muslim-majority state despite being a
muslim himself the 53 he when he was
arrested they was revolt the diversion
of anger on the streets it did not
convert itself into an armed uprising
there was very no nothing by way of an
armed uprising even in 1665 war when
once again there was an attempt by
Pakistan to seize by war what had not
been negotiated so far certainly there
was no evidence in the 71 then in 75 and
Sheikh Abdullah did come to an agreement
with the government of india the same
shape who had been under arrest we come
to an agreement and formed what was an
accord with Delhi and brought when he
came back to power brought the National
Conference back to part there was anyone
in the 1970s eight days six days would
agree that there was a period of
complete normalcy in Kashmir there was
no sign of an int of Indian troops there
was no sign of paramilitary forces there
was none of these stories of repression
etc and indeed there was no cross-border
terrorism either even Pakistan had
stopped between 65 and 89 89 88 87
something significant happens an
election takes place by this time
democracy is a practical reality in
Kashmir Sheikh Abdullah and national
conference are willing but for the first
time the National Conference of Sheikh
Abdullah is under threat of being
democratically unseated this happens in
in 1987 1987 and at that moment the
Government of India intervenes because I
remember it was the same time as the
Algerian Muslim front a Muslim united
front rises in Kashmir which by all
visible indications is ready to win the
elections because of disillusionment
against national conference and then a
national conference and Congress
alliance gets together in order to rig
the elections this is a fact and there
is no point pretending otherwise to rig
the elections and stop the muf from
coming to victory most I think if not
all most of the leaders of the present
who yet who are the most probably the
extremist organization in the valley
actually participated
themselves and where candidates in this
1987 election and sought their saw their
spinning seeds being snatched away by
corrupt by corrupt by corrupted
democracy and that led to a
disillusionment that led to street anger
that was encouraged by a by elements in
Pakistan who had been waiting for an
opportunity eventually leading to the
most bloody decade perhaps in Kashmir
history since the Afghans or perhaps
since the the rule of worst days of the
Jammu princes rule and coming to a
position which I think we will address
in the last part of the of the
discussion I think it well thank you
very much it's a great pleasure to be
here and I'd like to thank the
globalization center of yale's and mr.
president nine gender I i would just
like to in order to help myself and to
help you i hope i would like to divide
this into two basic issues the first is
Kashmir as a dispute between India and
Pakistan and how that has panned out
over the years and Kashmir is an issue
of self-determination an issue for the
Kashmiri people which is often neglected
a great deal Kashmir as a dispute I very
quickly sum up I mean I think you know
anyone with basic history of the
subcontinent knows it it has fueled
three walls between the two countries
1947 6571 and if you count Cargill 99
that three and a half wars and obviously
leading to enormous you know damage and
suffering on in both countries the
Kashmiris the Kashmir issue as a dispute
has fueled the new
your programs of both countries almost
entirely as far as Pakistan is concerned
and perhaps to a large extent for India
although India had another rival China
which it was also a felt it needed you
know to develop a nuclear weapon and
clearly the Kashmir dispute fuel the
nuclear tests in 1998 which bought both
these closet nuclear powers into the
open and created all the resulting
confusion in the world sanctions on both
countries etc and and really led to an
escalation I mean those nuclear tests if
you like were the sort of an escalation
of the Kashmiri conflict and led to them
the kargil conflict a year later in 1999
when the use of nuclear weapons was
bandied around a great deal what what
one could also says that the Kashmir
issue as a dispute between the two
countries have had enormous domestic
political effects in both countries it
has led to the military basically being
allowed to rule pakistan for almost 25
years they of meaning half its political
life because Pakistan and either for
constantly felt a threat from India on
the other side it has justified the
military to rule enormous budgetary
expenditure has gone towards the
military a lot of money that could have
gone for development and all the rest of
it has not been spent so Kashmir has
been used if you like as a justification
for the military to both rule and to
continue ruling as we see today on the
Indian side I think it has led to the
growth of Hindu fundamentalism the hindu
extremist parties in india the kind of
very strong anti-muslim bias that these
into groups have have had a very
dramatic effect in changing the indian
polity from which we knew right up to
the 80s if you like india as a secular
state india as a multi-ethnic state
india as a democratic state and
the whole rise of Hindu fundamentalism
is begins very closely linked to the
Kashmir issue a very strong feelings
against Pakistan and against partition
etc thirdly it has the without saying it
obviously it has led to enormous
economic deprivation in both countries
and human suffering in both countries
lastly I think Finn's the Cold War the
end of the Cold War in 1991 the failure
of both countries to be able to take
advantage or to be able to reject their
foreign policies in light of what was
going on in the rest of the world has
has resulted in a huge loss I mean again
probably more so for Pakistan that for
India but the fact is that you know
regionalism was then the byword for
economic success and political success
we saw the growth you know the expansion
of the European Union and ASEAN in
Southeast Asia and yet be although there
is a sock a south asian regional
cooperation it has not been able to take
off and in fact we have not seen any
kind of real regional coordination in in
South Asia and that has been a
tremendous loss because this is a
natural market it's a natural production
base the people share an enormous amount
and the fact that they're split up you
know by the borders has been devastating
and for example we see the war in
Afghanistan right now we're clearly you
know what would help of God guards would
be to be able to trade with India
Pakistan which was the historic market
for I've gone goods not now not being
able to do so because of you know they
can't get to India through Pakistan so
these are you know let me just move now
on to the second issue which is Kashmir
as an issue of self-determination
Kashmir first one has been a disputed
territory between the two countries
since 1947 it was the worst legacy of
partition I think by far it and and the
Kashmiri people have felt agreed because
you know as MJ has explained I mean you
know the up lever set was ordered it
never took place there was then a
UN resolution in the early 50s demanding
that it take place again it never took
place and there was a great Indian
hesitancy in allowing anything anything
like that to to take place not
necessarily because what they feared was
that the Kashmiri would go to Pakistan
but what was now being coming about in
amongst the Kashmiri themselves was an
enormous desire for independence the
prevacid actually only gave Kashmiri is
a choice between either voting to join
pakistan or voting to join india the
third option is it's called that is
independence was basically left out and
I think recent events a recent event
certainly have shown that the majority
of cash means would like to be
independent of both countries now we you
know we move swiftly up to nineteen
eighty nine the start of the present
Kashmiri insurrection Pakistan had tried
several times in fact to provoke an
insurrection in Kashmir against Indian
rule but it never took off most notably
in 1965 and I think in 1989 is generally
acknowledged that the insurrection was
indigenous completely it was a result of
enormous alienation of the communities
from rigged elections done by Delhi done
by the Indian government rig political
parties economic deprivation a whole
host of reasons there wasn't there was
first day a public and mass protest
followed by guerrilla actions in 1989
and and this is Direction really even
took Pakistan by surprise if you
remember this was a benazir bhutto had
just come in after ten years of military
rule she had met rajiv gandhi several
times there was hope that there would be
some kind of breakthrough in on the
subcontinent and then suddenly this
whole relationship between Rajiv and and
benazir was completely you know swamped
by if you like you know the Kashmir
insurgency which took everyone by
surprise especially as I say in Pakistan
oh it took parks and by surprise too
and we should remember the historical
time the Kashmiri insurgency starts just
when the Afghan conflict is winding down
1989 was the time of the soviet
withdrawal from afghanistan there could
have been a much bigger rapprochement in
the area also you know this was the
breakup of the Soviet Union you get the
end of the Cold War so the customer
insurgent if you like starts at in fact
a terrible moment for both countries
when both countries there was a lot of
international pressure and a lot of
international impetus if you like for
both countries to have got together when
when so and I think you know what you
see in 89 is really an expression of
enormous determination by the Kashmiris
that they they've had enough with India
they feel extremely alienated and that
of course has escalated in this last 13
14 years of insurrection and mass
movement in which you know the most
Kashmiris have become completely
alienated from what they perceive as you
know military suppression repression by
the Indians in in Kashmir itself and
it's been a horrendous human right story
the HP nor horrendous from both side
both from the insurgents and from the
Indian military it's been a it's been a
horrendous suppression of democracy in
what in what is the world's largest
democracy that is India now I think
watch has what really fuelly what led to
a kind of strategic shift in the
insurgency occurred in the mid-90s when
Pakistan started supporting not so much
the nationalist Kashmiri groups but the
Islamic fundamentalist groups who were
largely based in Pakistan made up to a
large extent of of Pakistanis and some
Kashmiris and this was a strategic shift
in there in the Pakistan military
thinking this was the same period 94 95
the Pakistan starts backing the Taliban
in Afghanistan and there was a desire if
you like to kind of subvert the
struggle by an Islamist one to turn if
you like the national struggle of
Kashmiri which many Kashmiris felt was a
nationalist struggle for independence or
autonomy or what you will into a jihad
you know into a jazzy struggle and I
think this was a very this was a
strategic mistake by Pakistan because
essentially what it did was that it
narrowed the options for Pakistan it
narrowed them visa visa Kashmiri people
and it narrows them visa V any kind of
dialogue with India and I think you know
once when and one spark son took that
step it was not possible for you to go
back to dump the jihadi then then go
back into supporting the the kind of
nationalist Kashmiri option and I think
that that strategic mistake has also led
to what we saw in the you know up to her
up to the mid nineties was this Indian I
mean the Kashmiri alienation against
India what you get now most recently i
think is a Kashmiri alienation against
these jihadi groups who are seen as
trying to subvert Kashmir yet or the
Kashmiri ethnic and linguistic and
religious traditions which are quite
separate from Muslims in other parts of
India or other parts of Pakistan so what
you know social Kashmir is an issue of
self-determination the oldest of this
still rests on India I mean India has to
deal with the Kashmir issue as an issue
of self-determination as to how it wants
to tackle it and what we saw in the last
13 or 14 years is India's refusal to
deal with the opposition movements of
militants the militant parties and only
now have you know very late in the day
but still hopefully not too late India
is beginning a dialogue with the with
the militant groups and with the
opposition and you know but I think
there's been a huge loss of time by the
Indians and a huge loss of opportunities
by the Indians in not doing this earlier
at the same time there is no way that
India is going to be able to
strike a deal with the kashmiris by
trying to keep Pakistan out of it I mean
there is a very strong feeling in India
that if we can just got a deal with the
kashmiris that back some can go you know
can kind of push off but the point is it
that the resolution to Kashmir dispute
hinges on for India to deal with issue
self-determination and for India and
Pakistan to collectively deal with a
width issue of Kashmir so not it's a
three-way deal which cannot be ignored
or forgotten about now very briefly I
mean you know post 9-11 what you see is
again you see a military regime in
Pakistan that was completely a pariah
state as far as the Americas were
concerned coming back into American
favor naturally because the Americans
needed Pakistan as a base against the
Taliban and al-qaeda and you see India
then at that point in time trying very
hard to depict Pakistan as a terrorist
change as a state that has supported you
know insurgency in Kashmir and trying to
influence world opinion in particular
American opinion that you know you
shouldn't be dealing with this country
this is a chair of state and I thought
that you know I mean that too has been
an enormous waste of time as far as the
Indians were concerned because it really
led to a completely negative policy to
all it towards the the global war
against Al Qaeda and it is only class
abated the india-pakistan dispute even
more with India trying to you know at
this time when box on was busy trying to
you know stem off al Qaeda and all the
rest of it on this eastern western
border having to deal with tensions on
its eastern border so the the only now
I've we seen I mean I think in the last
few months with the formation of the
Kashmiri committee and and perhaps these
Indian these elections now in Kashmir
the hope that India India of course in
the last one year's refused to talk to
Pakistan which has only led to
increasing frustration in Pakistan and
amongst the millet
and they have been exploring the facts
of militancy in Kashmir which have
killed hundreds of civilians over the
last 12 months I mean since nine eleven
and this has been very you know and let
it has led to two major escalations
between the two countries in January and
in june of this year now you know I mean
this all is a very depressing picture
but let me just end by pointing out a
couple of things that I'm very hopeful I
think the first thing is that as far as
the Pakistani perspective is concerned
the Indians have finally realized that
they have to deal with the kashmiris
they cannot relegate this to a Pakistan
aggression problem or a Pakistani
sponsored terrorism problem they have to
deal with the Kashmiris as a part of you
know as a political problem I think the
other thing is that for the first time
in India there has there is enormous
awareness amongst intellectuals the
media some of the political parties but
certainly not the hindu extremist
political parties and certainly perhaps
most mostly not in the in the present
ruling coalition of the BJP but there's
a huge I think awareness now that India
cannot wish away the Kashmir problem by
either dumping it with Pakistan and
being a permanent enemy of Pakistan or
by ignoring the Kashmiris and this has
been a huge shift and really it's been I
think more than anything it's being the
sacrifices or the depths of so many
Kashmiris over the last 15 years which
has led to the shift in Indian public
opinion and secondly I think it's been
the kargil conflict to some extent
ironically I mean that you know was it
was a very frightening moment in the
subcontinent when the use of nuclear
weapons or was very possible and I think
that at least in the Indian
intelligentsia has led to a much better
understanding of the situation and the
need to deal with it in Pakistan I think
there has been a similar shift in public
opinion I think there is a you know
Pakistan has suffered enormously
economically and politically because of
the kind of regime
changes we've had in the last 10 years
and now with this you know we've had a
military regime for the last real I
think there's been a huge shift there's
been first of all there's enormous
frustration against the army I think for
eating up the budget for having this
constant state of tension with India for
trying you know for funding these
militant groups and for making it
impossible for pakistanis to just settle
down and be normal human beings and live
normal lives and do business and and
progress and develop and I think there's
an enormous change in inbox Daly's
attitude now that you know they're fed
up with being manipulated by the
military to be constantly kind of be on
edge as it were within and I think box
and would like many parks aliens would
like a solution of course there many not
many but I think a minority who
certainly would not i mean the Islamic
parties and groups and the militant
certainly would not like anything like
that so I think in both countries i
think what needs to be done is to be
able to immobilize the this if you like
it's an elitist opinion it's an
intellectual media academic business i
mean i think business has been a huge I
mean businessman in both countries are
fed up with this dispute you know so how
can you want mobilize you know these
sort of peace lobbies if you like in
both countries to push their governments
forward to try and resolve this issue
but I think what we're seeing now is
kind of light on you know like at the
end of the tunnel with with events in
India and with with this change in
public opinion in both countries thank
you very much
as I mentioned at the beginning there is
a Nielsen poll that was just taken in
view of the elections to the state
assembly fashion but now are being held
angelica's the results of that pole and
I would like you to take three minutes
to comment on the main results of that
that's a background with the discussions
you may take a little more if I have
your permission than three minutes
because some of the details need bit of
fleshing and background the few points
that I think we need to appreciate and I
think without that you cannot have text
without context one of the reasons why I
think both Emma then I see a little bit
of hope not too much it's dangerous to
be optimistic is because of an event
which has not been referred to which is
actually 911 and I don't think there's
enough I don't know we remiss of me to
claim any saying but maybe there is not
enough recognition in America itself of
the implications and the impact of 911
and the change in American policy on
issues across the world now in short
what does actually 911 represent I don't
believe that any movement moves forward
or sustains itself without the semblance
of hope and if the kashmiri movement
sustained itself through the 1980s it
had two levels of hope one was the
militant level or the cross-border
terrorism by the way when it said that
India is not talking to Pakistan over
the last year there is a reason for it
India and Israel have both taken the
same position that they are ready to
talk but not ready to talk at after
being held hostage by the gun or being
held hostage by terrorism and this
position has been made very clear that
India is ready to talk to anyone at any
time but not if cross-border terrorism
is continuous and is encouraged by
Pakistan and if black will who is the
American ambassador in India three days
ago actually made a statement and he is
the American ambassador to India that
Pakistan support for cross-border
terrorism in August in September had
shot up significantly it is because
there is genuine evidence that there are
elements within the Pakistani government
and I do not believe that the whole
government Pakistani government probably
is involved in it but there are elements
who still have not quite given up the
hope that the gun will force and
basically will be able to weaken India
enough for India to withdraw I think
there is a continuing underestimation of
the will of the Indian state to protect
the geography that it inherited in 47
but the reason why 911 comes in and this
I have said even during my into the
kitchen with the couriers and so on is
because 911 has taken away one element
from the emerging kashmir picture which
is so far till then America had been
indifferent trailing to the use of what
what India definitely defines the
Starion ism in the Kashmir dispute but
after that the strong stand taken by
America with Islamabad in particular
that yes Kashmir will be brought to the
table Kashmir will be discussed but
Kashmir will not be discussed as long as
the you know there are elements and who
are entering as is happening yesterday
today and day before entering the valley
and using Pakistani weapons and
Pakistani training in order to put
forward their the case of the gun that
really has changed attitudes in the
Kashmir Valley of the Kashmiri movements
themselves now this does not make them
suddenly pro-indian it would be very
foolish and I think the opinion poll
that I will which was which I
commissioned on behalf of my newspaper
the Asian age and we used AC Nielsen
because we wanted an opinion poll which
had integrity which would be accepted
across the world we gave them full
freedom to ask any question they wanted
including questions which would be if so
facto on
in India the establishment does not
necessarily like issues like
independence to be discussed and raised
and so I now would like to present the
exact facts of the poll as they are
briefly quickly one of the issues that
was raised and raised by Pakistan you
know President Musharraf said that these
elections were a pass by going to be a
fast and the why would they be a fast
because they would be rigged and if they
were not rigged nobody would cooperate
and people were expecting and saying
that it would not get more than five
percent polling which would be a massive
rejection of Indian democracy by the
Kashmiri people sixty percent of
respondents in the state said that they
intended to vote now we did the pole
across all areas I wouldn't be one be
totally fair with you that means
including pro majority Jammu area
prabhudas Ladakh area and of course the
main muslim-majority Valley so even if
you shade out or eliminate the fact that
the weighted would include a higher
percentage in the Hindu or in the
Buddhist areas for polling you still get
a figure of almost fifty to fifty four
percent of the people willing to
participate in the elections the party
they would vote for about between 50 and
45 say it would be Farouk Abdullah's
national conference I discount this I
discount this figure myself because the
hurry up & shabu shabu are not
contesting the polls and indeed I asked
them to follow up and check what would
happen if the hurry ahead we're in the
in the fray and the findings are that
the Hurriyat Conference would pose a
serious threat to in sri nagar and
udhampur so it seems as if the hood its
support base also is still largely urban
where in the villages it is far more
evil the Congress I seems to have a lead
in Jammu which is as far as I'm
concerned good news because it means the
BJP is coming down there BJP has a
larger share of the vote in udhampur
that's a traditional BJP seat in fact
the whole of Jammu versa
to be really proved BJP the extremist
parties including those who want
trifurcation of the state we are
probably getting into detail and if you
find the detail too exhausting let me
know the the parties which are demanding
a traffic a shin of the state are
getting no support whatsoever no support
whatsoever now interesting thing is some
independent candidates are being now
many of the independent candidates are
actually proxy candidates of parties who
have officially boycotted the polls a
mood was created and i traveled to
kashmir on with the committee annals
individually and you know and i
certainly discovered this time that
there was far greater faith in genuine
poll as well isn't the right to use a
democratic option in order to in order
to carry the message forward so many of
the parties which have not been
contesting have foot approxi candidates
in order to get a place on the high
table or a place on the discussion table
if one emerges by November December
January as is the expectation I am NOT
going to get into the reasons why people
vote with us Korea have mentioned yes
there is they were we had some 600
respondents in this area who had asked
about whether they believed in Delhi's
assurance of a free and fair election
and sixty-two percent said yes that they
did believe it this time faruk
Abdullah's performance is very bad
ratings in fact he gets only half the
ratings of his party which means clearly
that if there was another party he would
lose the election he gets only
twenty-one percent Omar Abdullah same
thing repetition Omar Abdullah is son
Faruk son and anointed a okay the strong
opposition to far Abdullah Abdullah's
support and alliance with the BJP in
Delhi now let's come to the crux of the
matter Srinagar and an antenna and I we
said that let us take this
question only in the Muslim areas which
is the question of Independence where
the independence is the solution to the
Kashmir problem and there is no point
asking that in Jammu because Jammu does
not want independence and once union
with India 52-percent in Srinagar and
forty-one percent in anantnag or in you
these are figures statistics you can
turn them the other rounds and say
forty-eight percent in Srinagar and
fifty-nine percent in anantnag say that
independence is the solution what this
means is very interestingly is that what
was till probably two years ago and four
years ago a farm overwhelming support
for independence has over time whittled
down to even stevens analog is the most
radical or the most sort of extremist of
the cities and Srinagar itself is now
obviously a center of the hurry earth
and so on but even in Srinagar and
unearthed nog they it's a kind of half
half situation significantly almost
thirty percent in both these cities now
and I personally believe that this
figure would have been much less three
years ago almost thirty percent here and
would now be content with some form of
autonomy as a permanent solution and as
an end to violence why is this happening
incidentally there very few takers for
loc the line of control as a permanent
partition problem because Kashmir ease
don't want to be divided that's one
thing which comes across very strongly
and they are not interested in solving
India and Pakistan's problems at the
cost of cookies most interestingly
absolutely the the figures really range
in ninety five percent and upwards in
the Muslim areas ninety-five percent and
upward say very clearly they don't want
to go to Pakistan and this figure I
don't know if it surprises you not but
those who actually be are in fresh meat
and have dealt with them find this
absolutely understandable
because there is no support for the kind
of state that Pakistan has become in the
last 10-15 years particularly the post Z
estate and I know when we are talking to
people and so on I remember one person
student telling me I mean who the hell
wants to go and be ruled by generals and
the fact that you know army rule has
become so indistinguishable from
Pakistan as is having a continuing
impact on the Kashmiri mind and on the
reality of the region eighty-seven
percent right sixty-three percent feel
that India is serious about finding a
solution right I think we quickly get
down to its the rest is a repetition
really of the themes that I have already
enunciated in the sense that they
provide the same sentiment but a clear
91% feel that violence by militants will
no longer help in solving the Kashmir
problem and this is what i call the 911
impact they also across centers there is
consistent feeling among all communities
that it was absolutely wrong to drive
the Kashmiri pundits or the Hindus away
from the valley which was part of the
1994 strategy and happened at the time
when the Kashmiri movement was taken
over by the jihadi mu
then everybody again in the 90s agreed
that it was wrong for to drive the
Kashmiri pundits okay we now open the
floor for questions you mentioned a
little
you
we practically school that's one
has hopes push this you or skater from
government within the Constitution
create the other states as well so you
have a much more broader para that seems
to me to be given the strongly held
positions on
yeah I think I would remind you the to
you that you are not here at the
negotiating table for variable words so
we do encourage you to explore ideas of
what could mean a solution I understand
but you have said that at this point at
least partition for independence it's
not an option really does that could
lead to a very negative situation to say
the least so what are the options is
what professor is nabasa referring to a
possibility I we talked from the
perspective I think the most important
fact about Kashmir is not the moment
frozen here in the polls but what is the
trend of people's feeling a for example
the trend had been a continuous that
there is no option except separation
from India and that had been the trend
then you would have got one set of cells
but yes I think gradually there is say
one of the most important things I
believe that our committee achieved with
the who yet now who are you in India has
a kind of taboo status I mean you don't
discuss so you don't talk to low here
they are the bad guys they they're the
ones who want everything and I think one
comment made was was very relevant that
we are this committee is the first group
Indian group which Korea is actually
discussing now we have no you're very
right we haven't post I am locust and
away not negotiating table but the
agreements that have been reached
through our dialogue have come to I
think three important what would be
changing the bottom line of any future
negotiation one is that they have
accepted completely that violence and by
day within the OREA there is Javed meet
who actually introduce young man I mean
I have had interacted with him he
introduced the gun to do cash weed and
he know he says it in talking about 89
90 he accepts that know it was wrong and
violence is going to be out number two
very important is that no site can
afford no site can afford to remain
transfixed to old positions because if
you just stick to that then you are not
going to get any forward movement in
dialogue and for the hurry earth to say
this and I was at the press conference
with mere wise where publicly unless
this Sunday afternoon and I told him
that look you read out the agreement
it's important and he did then without a
form to call questions and was very
happy in making that assertion that we
have to now move from past positions and
number three we created words may not
mean much words we also mean very much
which is a solution that would be around
which would be in the phrase actually
suggested by them would be honorable
which really means that it would have to
honor kashmira sentiment acceptable
which is a code word that deadly would
have to accept it and sustainable which
is code that Pakistan would have to
accept it because if it is not accepted
by Pakistan as he pointed out then it's
not sustainable one of the reasons why
the kashmir accord with sheikh abdullah
Wharton was did not last more than one
generation was because it had no support
from across the border and therefore the
use of violence across the border which
is quite easy became you know quite
effective in it's a mental reaction
duval question one is how much does
general charge actually control his
government how many elements are there
that are pursuing agendas that he's not
in control of being on the giveaway at
all and secondly this seems to be a lot
of confusion still as to what his role
was during the Falcon cockpit and I
thought was to look too because actually
during that conflict to get a sense of
how he would respond to things workers
pay for the gaudiest views on kashmira
as separate from his views on terrorism
in general so he would wait well clearly
he had a decisive role in the kargil
conflict I mean you know he had just
become army chief and I think he wanted
to prove himself I think there were
generals around him who very keen to
push a line of confrontation and I think
you know he did play a decisive rule
there's no doubt about it the fact that
you know bajpai was coming to Pakistan
perhaps also you know I'm and that they
did not there was a conflict going on
between Nawaz Sharif the Prime Minister
and Jerry Musharraf whose army chief at
that time all these factors I think you
know led to the kargil conflict but
there's no doubt in anybody's mind inbox
on Utley said he did play a decisive
role as far as the other element is
concerned I think you know as far as the
government if you're thinking of the
intelligence agencies the inter-services
intelligence the ice I and other groups
I think certainly since 911 there has
been an enormous purging that has taken
place simply because the Americans that
the CIA was not prepared to work with
the I side the shape it was in the at
nine eleven a meaning that the parts on
intelligence were very intimately linked
with the Taliban and possibly with al
Qaeda elements inside of understand so I
think there is now much better control
over Kashmir policy
militants policy the sending or not
sending or buy by the government itself
and by the you know by President
Musharraf so I you know I don't think
this now is a valid argument I mean it's
although of course parks and denies it
that they're splits but it suits parks
and also to have this impression that
somehow sheriff is the good guy but that
they're bad guys who are not letting him
do the good thing you know so I think
what is really happening now is that we
shall I think everybody the Americans
everybody acknowledges Musharraf is in
control of the intelligence agencies or
whatever is happening is happening with
his permission it's not happening
without his finish so i think this puts
a lot more burden on on Musharraf if you
like then then then before briefly on
the question of alternatives i mean i
think you know the it's very difficult i
mean there are many many ideas but but i
think one of the most natural ideas
would be the idea of maximum autonomy
for kashmir now within the within the
indian union now what part of kashmir
gets maximum autonomy there's always get
orders just the muslim-majority areas
get or do the Hindu majority areas get
how would this be taken in the rest of
India you know by the by all the
political parties by how would this this
woulda put this need an amendment to the
Constitution anyway so there would be
huge problems to some out and I'm not
belittling them in a sense but clearly
this would be moving towards that kind
of maximum autonomy would be one way of
I think trying to satisfy her show me
anger and hunger and I think there would
have to be some major steps towards
reconciliation you know regarding the
human rights abuses that have taken
place regarding the killings that have
taken place much is the situation today
in Afghanistan how do you resolve this
problem of past conflict 15 years of
blood you know sixty thousand dead the
and here of course India would have to
take the initiative this is not
something which
we can do kind of on their own
because that implies control
it also pays ask a question here is
where
election
the declaration
so there is a false impression on what
happens to pakistan's not satisfied by
your proposal maximum so if we take MJ's
position which is that all rigidities
about past positions
there's
and we try to adjust 30 honorable
jeans coming up the solution
all three of those
No
so push the boat and others
my
control that has to address heart
attacks until that time so there are
elements
which is so today let me just say I mean
I think I would acknowledge and I think
many people in Pakistan would
acknowledge maybe the army would not
acknowledge but clearly the relationship
between the box on government and
Pakistani Kashmiri would have to alter
considerably in any kind of ultimate
settlement and it has not even well I
think maximum autonomy the same thing
that one is asking for in Indian cashew
now how you would link to to Kashmir's
together what state is the line of
control would have you know i mean but i
think the essential relationship between
the states and the two canoes has to
change before any settlement takes place
you know before any kind of settlement
takes place now exactly what formulation
that would take I mean you know I really
have no idea and I I don't have many
ideas about it but I can I can
understand that you know we would you
know the army would have to accept also
I mean exactly what you're talking about
the kind of manipulated poles you know
that you've had in our Dartfish million
Pakistani fish meal would not be
permissible in a kind of final
settlement so but but but on the other
side I think you know there is that I
think there is no way that India is
going to be able to budge I mean here
you have India as a stronger power India
has a most of the cards in its hand
Pakistan has a spoiler role that it can
play in delaying a settlement fudging a
settlement making a settlement
unworkable but Boxton does not have you
know even half the cards basically so I
think the ultimate thing of a settlement
as far as independence is concerned is
not acceptable to India and it's
probably not
acceptable to any of the big powers
around South Asia Russia China you know
America etc because it raises a whole
heap of issues for China for Russia you
know for Central Asia where there are
huge ethnic and political problems now
so you know I think yeah I think the
issue of maximum autonomy has not really
been explored properly by either the
countries yeah I can see where Larry is
coming from and with the best of
intentions but i have actually strongly
believed and have argued this to the
extent that one makes a difference which
is not very much it is that you can't
really solve the problem in fish wheel
and if you look for solutions we are not
going to find any everybody is just too
rigid but you can probably melt the
problem and i use the word advocate that
concept very strongly that melted by
moving away from the rigidity now how
how in practical terms you melt it
autonomy obviously i mean if you raise
the question of independent Kashmir the
the country which would block it
instantly is not America India Pakistan
the countries that block it is China
because China is not going to surrender
the parts of cash meet that have been
handed over to China by they are you
found agreement but be that as it may
India is not going to accept the
independence of Kashmir America has made
it very clear that it is not ready to
accept the independence of Kashmir
because it believes that a small nation
in that particular position will become
a breeding ground for terror which will
have a very weak government and so on
and so forth right now given the fact
that you have a problem and you have
these hard lines I think the autonomy
idea has to be accepted in principle by
as a concept and the amount of stretch
ability or the tensile strength of the
idea that is now being given by Delhi is
quite substantial there is a minister
ex-minister who has been nominated arun
jaitley to talk as far
as is possible there was a move before
the Agra summit where vodka actually it
escaped in one of his speeches and then
he quickly withdrew which was to soften
their line of control what are we
actually looking for you are looking for
a problem it's 44 Kashmiris so soften
the light of control and open up border
points and check for so that kashmiris
can go and meet each other and see this
is melting the problem and create
harmony between the two people that
makes them give them a vested interest
in slowly providing a solution or
reaching gradually moving towards a
solution that might eventually I I know
the idea that that larry has advocating
in his proposed which is a new kind of
sovereignty now the problem with that is
not a new kind the problem with that is
the word sovereignty and nations are not
willing to give sovereignty as far as
stocks are concerned I mean Government
of India has been talking to the Naga
secession is well ever since it still
continues to talk to them so I don't
think we dead he has a problem in
talking per se but Delhi has a problem
in surrounding sovereignty I think once
sort of slightly facetiously but Unni
want to make a point and don't know how
else to get it through you use the
during the height of cargill which
actually was the last attempt by we have
actually had two and a half walls 71 was
over bangladesh over kashmir but during
colloquial I said you know let the
Indian flag clients Srinagar and
pakistani flag fly in muzaffarabad and
hand over the LOC to the Americans
something but within these sort of semi
jokes was any options all are one is
trying to suggest that thing because we
for you nuclear war is a theoretical
fact for us which is a very practical
fact and I know how close she is in law
and I'm in Delhi how close we came this
summer towards the unthinkable and that
unthinkable believe me is not going to
leave only 12 million Indians and
Pakistanis read it is going to leave the
whole region from China to
when East Africa devastated and beyond
the reach of any national resource is
natural resources and its people beyond
the reach of the world it will change it
would change the world before in ways we
dare not even imagine
peace
normal
I
this
until at situation so once
that
lady
so beyond the porch
there's also the issue of
they
well you know I think I mean of course
one of the major problems you've had
over questionnaire is simply that the
Indians do not accept international
mediation or international help towards
dialoguing with Pakistan in Pakistan is
desperately seeking international
mediation and you had this issue for the
last so many years you know poles apart
from each other now I think you know
since nine eleven I think there's been a
much greater willingness on India side
it will not say that the Americans
intervening or but I think there's been
a much greater willingness to accept a
role for America and America is being
very subdued about it's not trying to
push itself but it's reading but I think
you know what I mean the point you're
talking about the real issue here is
that you know what you've seen by by the
US has been damage control consistently
and persistently so things flare-up
escalation more about to do you know the
US comes in and throws in a few you know
exerts enormous pressure and think I
mean I think what path time would like
to see would be a much more concerted
international effort and I think we have
come a long way in the last few months I
think events that have taken place in in
delhi in city nagar and all but for
example the he ii rakesh i mean i think
there's a real fear that Iraq is going
to completely you know push away u.s.
involvement in Kashmir just as it might
push away u.s. involvement in abundance
so I think you know i'm i think the
international community has to be
involved in a more sustained way that is
as shown in over the last 50 years that
it cannot just walk away from the issue
the moment that the detention DNA
i would like to mention that his look
what is value breaker situation as five
America there is no explicit mention
fashion
ready here to make them
be very careful attention not seeing
I would actually like to add a point
isn't this they there is actually a very
significant change in delhi on this
issue of international mediation while
there may be a technical I mean you
really hear it from the Congress some
old foreign minister who had a viewpoint
in 1974 you know going on an issue
statements but there is broad
recognition among all political parties
that whether they say it or not and
certainly think that we have argued that
once you become nuclear an issue like
this is no longer daily bilateral and
the world is has to be for saying
interested in it's no longer a doc patch
fight so don't pretend it is and I think
the serious people in Delhi have
accepted that they may not readily
articulate it because they do not want
Pakistan to take immediate advantage of
it and call a madrid or call an Oslo or
whatever but I mean why do you think
Richard Armitage is more often in Delhi
than he's in Washington he's not going
there to you know check out the prices
and it is a very good point is this very
good point that was be made because I
think America respects that Indian
sensibilities I think point amith also
made have to be kept in mind because
when the time comes for giving in the
kinds comes for creating space to find a
solution it is Delhi villa which will
have to create a space to find the
solution so this is an important change
and I think you will find this reflected
over the next year one last question
he'll have talked about me what if you
had talked about the domestic utility of
the Kashmiri shoe by the Sun and I was
wondering if you could talk about the
role that plan has played in Pakistan
objects and if you see an agreement that
we should say you have peaceful
negotiation process from establish the
vacuum that would create and the size of
the nature of the vacuum
in a sense of our population respond
tell me that is a fair ball or serving
it's been done improperly
I you know I think it's you've asked a
very very good question and an extremely
difficult one you know Kashmir has
become if you like I mean anti-india
being anti Indian has become a kind of
one of the resort dates for Pakistan's
continued foreign policy tool I can't
and survival it's become certainly a
resort dates for the military to retain
power in the country and to direct a lot
of the budget and a lot of the the
interest towards it what I mean
basically you're asking what would fill
the vacuum if there was peace tomorrow
if peace was to break out I mean I
answer for that quite honestly but i
think what what the only thing that
could fill the vacuum would be a a
genuine I mean stepping back of the
military and a lying civil society to
come into you know I wouldn't say a
democratic flowering because that's not
likely to happen in Pakistan you know
overnight but I you know where I
disagree with you i mean i think i think
the most that the best that we can hope
for at the moment is a car which was
shown of himself is not willing to do at
the moment he's a civil military
partnership for a limited period of time
in which a civilian government is there
but the military has give makes a
commitment that you know once is it once
a government is able to run its entire
course and hand over to the next
government through a proper election
which is what we've ever had by the way
I mean we've never had an elected
government handing over power to another
electrical then you know the military
would step back from a from it's very
proactive role in foreign policy and
economic policy at all so I mean what
I'm suggesting is that for a period of
time there will have to be a a civil
military alliance in which gradually the
Civil is allowed by the military to
become more powerful now is that
possible certainly in these elections
that are coming up on October tent
Musharraf has rejected that Musharraf
wants total control he wants to have a
rigged election which is going to give
total control to the military and it's
going to create its own series of crises
subsequently for Pakistan nothing to do
with India so in my opinion it's a very
dangerous moment at the moment in
Pakistan's history because of course
it's coming together with 911 with India
Kashmir everything is kind of you know
sitting there on your head but I mean as
I said the only the only way you can
fill this vacuum but the vacuum you are
asking about is to is to allow this
supremacy gradual supremacy of civilian
rule and civil society you also want to
thank jay for these very interesting
presentations which I think
cool thank you very much